The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: Good
morning, everyone,
and good evening in Singapore.
Where is everyone?
AUDIENCE: I think
they are on the way.
We'll be here in a minute.
DUANE BONING: OK, I'm going
to go ahead and start.
What I wanted to do is, I sent a
message around about these team
guidelines, so--
our team project guidelines.
So I'm not going to
go into great detail
through these slides.
Hopefully, everybody
is well on the way
towards identifying a team.
But I wanted to go
quickly through this
and then answer
any questions you
may have on the team projects.
Quick reminder that the
team projects are about 20%
of the grade.
So they are an
important part of this.
The basic expectation
is, this is
where you get a chance to
dive deep into the analysis
and exercising of some of the
kinds of tools and approaches
we've been talking about
with a set of data.
Our hope is that you
can find data yourself.
Through the various
members of the class,
I think, in one of the
earlier problem sets,
we asked for your experiences,
perhaps with some past data.
I think there's
plenty of data around.
If you are not able to
tap into some past data
you or colleagues have
generated in the lab,
in a previous job
that you can share,
or whatever, you can also
tap into the literature.
So if you find data
in the literature,
that is perfectly fine as well.
And then, in a few
cases, we actually
have some data from our own
experimentation and research.
So if you're really stuck, let
me know or let Hayden know.
And we can try to connect
you up to something.
I've listed a few topic areas.
I don't want these
to be limiting.
But I mean, these are
the main kinds of topics
we've been dealing
with in the class,
things like process
diagnosis-- looking at the data
to detect problems; ways
of optimizing or improving
the process through design
of experiments, optimization,
and so on; and then some other
sort of advanced applications,
things like nested variants,
some of the spatial yield
modeling, that sort of thing.
So I think it works well
to have three or even
four members in the team.
So the goal is have a
fairly rich data set,
and have multiple members of the
team applying different kinds
of analyses to the problem, OK?
So I think it does
work where you're
able to identify contributions
from each of the team members.
But the whole point
of this is actually
to be able to pick over the
data, talk about the data,
talk about your
approach to analysis,
and looking at the problem
with your teammates.
Thursday, the project
proposal is due.
This is just one or two pages
describing the basic data,
the basic problem in
your plan for attack,
what kinds of analyzes
you hope to do.
And of course, list who
your team members are
and what their roles are.
The goal then is, over the
coming week, and maybe even
starting, perhaps, even after
class for folks in Singapore,
on Thursday, and
certainly on Tuesday,
to have a chance to meet with
me or Dave, if he's available,
to basically go over your
plan and your analysis
so far, if you're
partway through it.
So we'll need to do
that by video conference
with folks in Singapore.
If we do it right after
class, we can probably
try to arrange this facility.
Otherwise, we'll use the
conference room near the SMA--
your SMA offices.
Then the expectations
are two parts.
There will be a
group presentation.
By the way, not necessarily
every single member
of your team needs to present
part of the presentation.
Trying to have 14 members
in a 15-minute chunk often
can be kind of a
coordination mess.
So as a team, you need to
put together a presentation,
and have one or maybe
two people, most likely,
presenting some
of those results.
And then at the end of
that week, on Friday,
May 16, which is the end of
the term given that we do not
have a final exam, a
single shared group report
needs to be submitted.
These are just some
example topics.
I'm not sure if those have
been drawn from past semesters
or not.
Here's some additional
kinds of suggestions
that I mentioned--
kinds of analyses
that might be of interest.
In the report-- these
are some guidelines
on what we'd like to
see in the report.
One note here, and I
haven't posted it yet, is--
whoops-- is we'd like to
use a common template just
for the formatting
and guidelines.
And basically, the
IEEE two-column format
has worked really nicely.
We have Word templates.
I think we even have
LaTeX templates if there's
anybody who still uses LaTeX.
I will post that
template on the web.
What's nice about that is we
can actually then put together
all of the written reports
from the class into almost
a little booklet.
And it almost looks like
a little mini journal,
or a little mini conference
proceeding, if you will,
with these reports.
It also is a nice,
professional looking report.
So we'll distribute
that as well.
So finally, I just grabbed,
from the past two or three
years, some of the titles
from some of the process--
or team report
and presentations,
just to give you a little
bit of a sense of the variety
of kinds of things that we saw.
So those might
give you some idea.
By the way, back in 2005,
we were more focused
on, like, two-person projects
or one-person projects.
And these were great reports.
But we did decided that
sharing and interacting
made things a better
learning experience for all.
So with that, let me open it up.
Anybody have questions
on how the team
reports, team projects, team
presentations need to go?
I'll try to break--
does pretty much everybody
have a team in formation?
Are there people who
kind of are still
looking for possible partners?
OK, one or two.
OK, I'll try to break maybe
five minutes earlier--
which may mean actually
break on time--
at the end of class, so could
be a little bit of discussion
while people are still
face-to-face on that.
Any other questions on that?
AUDIENCE: Professor?
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just
now, you mentioned
having a rich set of data.
So from my understanding,
we are supposed
to do the experiments ourselves.
So I would like to know
how big a set of data
are you expecting?
DUANE BONING: Well,
my expectation,
or minimal expectation
I would say,
is more that you
might be able to tap
into data that has already
previously been generated.
It's ambitious,
and I would applaud
people wanting to go and
generate additional data.
So we could certainly talk,
and depending on the data
you have in mind.
But what I mean by
rich set of data
is something that will support
enough of the kinds of analyses
that we've been talking
about through the term.
So if it's a DOE,
it needs to be,
you know, probably several
parameters of input,
several parameters of output.
Maybe you have some
additional twist to it
that's kind of interesting
or non-standard that included
some thorny issues in the data.
Maybe it's an unbalanced
design, or an imperfect design,
and you have to try
to accommodate that.
All I mean is enough
data to do what
you would like to propose
to do and that we can
talk about finding acceptable.
So were you actually looking
at going in and generating
some data on one of the
processes, or tools,
or equipment there?
AUDIENCE: My group haven't
had a discussion yet.
At first, we talk taught
this as a requirement.
DUANE BONING: OK, yeah,
so we can follow up
with Hayden on that.
I think bonding and that
sort of thing would be great.
So we won't be too ambitious.
It will be doable.
OK, other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think
maybe as an example
of all kind of
manufacturing processes,
but I have a passed out data for
kind of material engineering.
Is that OK if I can use
material engineering data?
DUANE BONING: Sure,
so the question was
is material engineering
data, mechanical processes,
mechanical properties,
is that OK?
And the answer is absolutely.
I mean, if you look at some
of these past projects,
you've got everything from
some things that look kind
of like semiconductor stuff--
laser diode, it's
not transistors.
But you have other things
of bending printed circuit
boards, sheet metal blanket,
surface quality in milling,
all kinds.
This is sort of general
manufacturing and general
processes.
So that would be
no problem at all.
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Prof, can you
post more of the reports
on Stata so we can take a look?
DUANE BONING: Yeah, I think
what we've done in the past
is put up some example--
some of the prior year reports.
We haven't posted those yet.
But I'll try to do that today.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
DUANE BONING: OK,
any other questions?
All right, let me switch here.
So again, what
we're doing now is
sort of switching to
some case studies.
There's still, perhaps
in a few of the lectures,
some new material, if
you will, coming along.
In this case study--
the first case study--
I don't think there's actually
that much new in terms
of methodologies, and so on.
I just think this is a nice
example, though a little
dated now, of a fairly
straightforward but thorough
application of design of
experiments and response
surface modeling.
So I also, by the way, posted
the paper for this case study
on the site as well.
It's down in the reading
section that goes--
readings that goes
with the lecture.
So you'll have to go
and pop off this--
what is it-- eight or
nine page paper as well.
I should mention, some
of the other case studies
will also have papers from
the literature for you
to grab and read.
So this case study comes from
semiconductor manufacturing.
It's a little dated now.
It goes back to 1991.
But this was actually
kind of just the time
when things like statistical
process control, more
thorough design of experiments,
response surface modeling
was really finally hitting
the semiconductor industry,
and really starting to be
more widespread in adoption.
So I think this is a nice case.
It's a nice case study
because they actually
show us the experimental
conditions, the actual data,
and the actual models
that they generated.
Some of the things
are a little dated.
For example, they talk
about 125 millimeter wafers.
So this was 5-inch
wafer processing,
which is kind of a weird size.
But it also-- we're up to 300
millimeter, 12-inch wafers.
So it shows the march of--
progress of technology.
However, CVD and CVD
of blanket tungsten
is still heavily used
and very integral.
So it's still a
relevant process.
So what I want to do in looking
at this case is go through,
talk a little bit
about the background
of tungsten CVD, things
that aren't in the paper
but may give you a
little bit of a feel on--
more of a feel on the
process; talk a little bit
about the preliminary work
that they did looking back
at the prior paper
that they cite;
and then we'll go through
the experimental design
that they performed to try
to optimize this tungsten CVD
process, to understand it,
model it, and then optimize it.
So we'll look at the data.
We'll do some RSM
analysis, or mostly looking
at their analysis in the paper.
But assuming I have time at
the end, and I think I will,
I'll switch over.
And we'll use-- play around
with JUMP a little bit with that
same data set, and show you a
few of the kinds of analyses
that are possible with that
tool, both for regression--
some of the stepwise
regression that's
referred to in the paper--
and then some of
the neat tools that
actually in the interactive
capabilities of JUMP
for optimization.
Now throughout this,
think a little bit
about where you see weaknesses,
or alternative ideas,
or things like that.
Because at the end,
I might ask, what
are some of your
ideas of things you
think might have been
interesting, or important
to try or to improve on this.
So have that in mind.
Where do you think
they did a good job?
they did a weaker job?
What might you suggest?
And I'll ask you that
question at the end, OK?
So let me talk a little
bit about tungsten,
and in particular,
tungsten plugs.
So tungsten, here, is
generally used as a conductor
in semiconductor fabrication.
It's not a great
conductor, meaning
it's often a little bit higher
resistivity than other metals,
like aluminum or, now, copper.
However, it continues
to be heavily used
for contacts and plugs.
So contacts are the holes
that are drilled between--
into an insulating layer
from the first level of metal
down to the underlying silicon.
Plugs are the same idea, but at
other levels of interconnect.
So you would have a plug
from metal one to metal two,
or metal two to metal
three, and so on.
Terminology is not
completely uniform.
But that's the
typical terminology.
The examples drawn
from this paper,
they talk about tungsten
plugs in conjunction
with aluminum interconnect.
And they're actually
mostly focused, I think,
on tungsten between--
or tungsten contacts, with the
idea that in older technology,
in fact, you didn't
need to drill and form
separate plugs between layers.
You could just allow, say,
an aluminum deposition
to go in and fill that
layer, and then etch off
where you didn't want it.
With scaling, it
became pretty much
essential to be able to
form the plugs separately
from the interconnect.
So then, tungsten was used to
fill those plugs between metal
layers, as well.
As we've gone to
copper interconnect,
tungsten still appears in most
advanced technologies, now
primarily just as the first
level of contact from a copper
interconnect down
to the silicon.
So it is still used, and
extensions where it may not
purely be tungsten plugs, but
it may also be, in some cases,
some local interconnect.
So you can, down very
close to the silicon,
form little straps
or other sorts
of local tungsten-based short--
very short-run interconnect
to form electrical connections.
Now, the important part of
tungsten-- why it's used--
is that it also can be
formally filled, and can,
especially with chemical
vapor deposition,
or plasma processing, can
fill fairly small holes.
So the basic idea or progression
in a tungsten deposition
is you primarily get
conformal deposition.
So in time, the gases that are
present in the plasma chamber
and reactor interface
with the surface
form reactions, and basically
build up in a conformal way
to fill the plug.
Now, you want to do
this in a way that
does not result in seams
or voids in the middle.
So that can be a
little bit tricky.
But that can be
done in such a way
that one avoids those plugs.
Now, the way this paper
uses tungsten plugs is
with a process they refer
to as plasma etchback.
So if I do that conformal
deposition, finally,
to this the surface, now I've
got the tungsten not only in
the plug, but I've also got
all this excess tungsten
out here in the neighboring
regions that I want to remove.
And the idea of etchback was
that through that deposition
process, I filled the
surface, but I leave,
essentially, a nearly
planar surface that now,
if I just etch uniformly
back that whole surface,
I can remove down to the
underlying interface metal
or interface layer,
or the oxide,
and leave the metal just in
the plug where I wanted it.
In the paper, they
refer to using this as--
using plasma etchback to
do this uniform etchback.
In modern processing,
this step has pretty much
been replaced with
CMP, because that
has a much higher
controllability,
and gets around an
important limitation that's
kind of pictured here
in this diagram having
to do with very tight
constraints on uniformity
with a plasma etchback.
The basic issue with
uniformity is if I, in fact,
have deposition that results
in different thicknesses--
either in different locations
within the chip or in different
chips across the wafer--
and I uniformly
etchback, first off,
if I only etchback this
amount in both regions,
then I have not completely
removed what I needed to
in the other regions.
So I have to make sure
I do enough over-etch
to at least clear off and make
sure I don't have any shorts
anywhere on the wafer.
And when you do
that, to make sure
that I'm down to the surface
in the thickest area,
you get over-etch lossage
in the thinnest regions.
So you have a fairly
tight constraint then
on what the thickness
uniformity is,
as well as the etch uniformity,
in order to achieve that, OK?
So the paper does talk a
bit-- and in fact, we'll
see later, explicitly models
the wafer uniformity as one
of the outputs in order to try
to understand, as they play
with some of the
process conditions,
how uniformity is
going to be affected
by their choice of
these conditions.
There's a couple of other
interesting aspects of plasma
etchback that are important,
as well, in particular,
help inform the modeling
that this paper undertakes.
And that has to do
with surface roughness.
So not only will these sorts
of features, this topography
like that little dimple there--
but also, if the
surface of the film--
the deposited film-- is rough,
and I do a uniform plasma
etchback, sort of a
vertical plasma etchback,
that surface roughness
can in fact then--
this is rough.
That, in truth,
may be transmitted
to the final
surface of the plug.
So another important parameter
that they will be explicitly
modeling is tungsten--
the deposited
tungsten roughness.
And generally, less
rough is better.
It's going to give a
better surface quality,
less prone to defects,
more uniform in resistance,
and so on.
That, by the way, is another
reason for switching to CMP.
CMP planarizes-- can
deal with not only
this kind of surface
topography on a large scale,
but it also smooths the surface
on sort of the atomic scale.
And so you tend to get
much, much higher quality
final plugs.
OK, any questions
on basic tungsten--
a little lesson
on tungsten plugs.
So let's talk a little bit
about the process equipment
and the process
parameters that are
going to be in this case study.
This is a schematic
cross section
of an Applied Materials
Precision 5000 reactor
configured for tungsten CVD.
By the way, this
is a classic tool.
The P5000-- AMaP P5000, there's
one of these in the Smithsonian
Institute.
It was the tool that made
Applied Materials what
it is today.
It was one of the first
single-wafer processing
tools that really
gave good control
over the atmospheric conditions
for deposition, for etching,
these sorts of things.
So we're seeing a glimpse back
into history here even looking
at this cross section.
By the way P5000's are still
in use all over the place.
We have some--
I guess just one in MTL, I
think mostly for etching.
But even in some FABs
I still run into them.
They've been scaled
up, and improved,
and configured-- changed
in configuration,
but they are still around.
So the basic idea
here is that the wafer
will sit here on a susceptor
in this plasma reactor--
this low pressure
plasma reactor.
In fact, there
are usually pins--
I think three or four pins--
that hold the wafer.
The robot loads the
wafer in onto these pins.
And then the pins--
these lift fingers
here, I guess--
recede.
And the wafer then
sits on the susceptor.
This susceptor is
optically heated.
So there are these heat lamps.
I think there's something
like 1,000 watt heat
lamps in this configuration
that heat up and hold
the temperature of the whole
platen, the whole susceptor.
There's then gas flow
coming in from a gas feed.
There's a little
mixing chamber in here
so that you can mix different
combinations of different gas
flows.
And then it goes
through a shower head.
This thing right
here is typically
referred to as a shower head.
And you can imagine,
it's basically
like a shower head
in your shower.
It's got holes in
it that basically
allow the gases to
flow through, hopefully
in a fairly uniform
distribution across the surface
of the wafer.
And then there's
a vacuum control,
and a number of different vacuum
outlets for the gases to flow.
So some of the key inputs--
there's lots and lots of knobs
to control on these equipment.
Some of the key inputs that
are used in this study--
in the paper that
we're looking at--
are gap space temperature, H2
pressure, and WF6 pressure.
So the gap space
refers to, I believe,
essentially the height
of this susceptor.
One can play with the
distance between the gas
inflow and the wafer, moving
it between, say, 2 to 4
or 5 inches.
And that changes a number of
the plasma characteristics.
It changes perhaps some of
the gas flow characteristics.
It may also change some of
the thermal characteristics.
So it is a control parameter
that is not entirely obvious
up front how it affects the
growth of-- or deposition
of this tungsten.
So that's going to be one
of the parameters that needs
to be empirically studied.
Certainly, temperature
is going to have
a very strong effect in this
process on things like growth
rate, perhaps also the surface
morphology or the roughness
of the film, the amount of
incorporation of tungsten,
and the ultimate
resistivity of the film--
those sorts of parameters.
And then, both hydrogen and
tungsten hexafluoride gas flow
pressures will also be
clearly of influence
in rate resistivity and so on.
So this is kind of a neat
paper, because they actually
are measuring about eight
different parameters
and modeling each of them.
So it's kind of a four input,
eight output kind of DOE.
So just to go through some of
these parameters, many of them
are pretty obvious,
but a couple of them
I want to explain a little
bit more so that you have
a good feel for what they are.
Deposition rate, I think
that's pretty obvious.
Generally, you would like
to have a fairly high rate.
It's going to make
the process time
as short as possible, efficiency
in the tool use, and so on.
The paper mentions wanting
to have about 500 nanometers
a minute-type rates
with these processes.
The resistivity
value-- or rho here--
generally, you kind of
want a low resistance,
or a low resistivity film.
An interesting twist
here is, depending
on the application, the
actual resistivity you want
and whether it's all that
low actually changes.
So for example, if you're
using it as a short run metal
wire, pretty much all the time,
low resistance is important.
But it turns out, interestingly,
when you use tungsten plugs
in conjunction with
aluminum layers,
you may actually want
the tungsten plug
to be a little bit higher
resistance than the aluminum
itself, so that, because it's a
very small, constrained spatial
area, the higher resistance
causes the current flow
to spread out a little
bit more uniformly,
and actually improves the
reliability of these tungsten
plugs.
So you'd actually like to
understand what the resistance
is and be able to tune that in.
So that's going to motivate
some of the modeling
that that's done here.
It's not always purely a
lower resistance is better.
RS uniformity refers to
sheet resistance uniformity.
This is the ohms per
square of sheet resistance,
but then a uniformity
number calculated
for that measured
sheet resistance
across the entire wafer.
And so you want a
very good uniformity.
The 3% non-uniformity number
is the deviation-- percentage
deviation of the thickness.
Sort of one standard
deviation over mean
is what they're referring
to in here, I believe,
for this uniformity.
And again, one of
the motivations
there is that uniformity
in the plasma etchback,
you want to avoid
recess of these plugs
in some region which can make
it difficult for the subsequent
aluminum to reach down in and
actually contact those recessed
plugs.
Film stress is another
important parameter.
Let me see if I've got
other slides on that.
No, not much.
Essentially, there is
a volumetric mismatch
to the deposited
tungsten compared
to the underlying
silicon substrate wafer.
And in fact, what
you'd typically
find is that the
wafer will undergo--
or be in tensile stress.
So basically, there's more
volume in the deposited film.
And it's causing a thick--
a layer, depending on the
thickness of the layer--
in fact, in the design, they're
talking about two different
thicknesses that they explore--
that causes the wafer to bow.
So I've got a film that wants
to spread out a little bit more,
especially at lower
temperature compared
to the temperature
of processing.
And that wafer bow
is a nice indicator
of intrinsic internal
stress in those films.
In general, you don't
want stress mismatches
between different
layers on your wafer,
because that means there's
sort of this excess energy
around that would like
to release itself.
And one way it
releases itself is
by having those
layers delaminate, OK?
So a reliability concern is
to try to avoid very high
stresses in order to support
subsequent processing
and long-term reliability of
the material on the wafer.
So they are making some
measurements of film stress.
In fact, the way they make
this measurement, I believe--
if I remember right--
is they measure the wafer bow.
And then, based on assumed
numbers for the Young's modulus
and perhaps the thickness--
they may measure the thickness
separately--
they basically
calculate or estimate
what the film stress is.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And that's
originally CTE mismatch?
DUANE BONING: I believe
that it is CTE mismatch,
that in some sense, at
whatever temperature
you're doing, if you
could deposit the film
and keep the wafer at
300 degrees, or 100
and whatever it is,
at that point in time,
I don't believe
the wafer undergoes
or experiences much stress
during this deposition.
But then, it's a temperature
expansion difference.
I'm not entirely sure of that.
It's possible that the
simple incorporation
at the time of deposition
also has some stress.
But really, we're talking
about intrinsic stress that--
or extrinsic stress that remains
at the end of processing.
You know any more
on that, Hayden?
AUDIENCE: Sounds reasonable.
I mean, there are
situations where
you're depositing an
epitaxial layer of, say,
a semiconductor, that has a very
clearly defined lattice, whose
picture is mismatched with
the substrate underneath.
In that case, there's a--
I guess a definite
built-in stress
that's going to result
in that deposition
but isn't connected with
thermal contraction.
But I would have thought,
in this situation,
it's mostly to do with
the presence of impurity
is changing the CTE of the
deposited layer that stretched.
DUANE BONING: Good.
The fifth parameter that
they measure and model
is step coverage.
And so here, that refers
to essentially how good
the deposition process is--
I know you've read here--
in filling these features.
Now, if all of your features
are exactly the same size,
then that's a little bit easier.
So if all you're doing
is filling contacts
of exactly the same
size, then you've
got a nice, well-defined
number for step coverage.
And that's really what they're
doing in this application.
But I should mention that these
kind of conformal depositions
can actually be a very
strong challenge for dealing
with patterns or features
of different sizes.
So you can imagine, for example,
having some contacts here,
having some structures that
might in fact be lines,
and then having some
other structures
that are in fact
very wide lines.
And now, if I can
formally fill, I
might be able to fill
the narrow structures,
but the wider ones will not
necessarily fill completely.
I won't have excellent
step coverage.
Now, I believe what they're
doing in this paper is really
just looking locally
after the deposition,
and looking to see sort of
what percentage of volume
is missing in that little
indentation resulting
from the conformal deposition,
and looking for fairly high--
near 100%-- step coverage,
so that there's not
a missing percentage of the
feature compared to, say, one
of these large structures that
might have a very high missing
volume.
Generally, they're able to
achieve fairly high step
coverages.
So that's not one of
the critical output
parameters in this process.
Now, also shown on this
picture, and maybe a little bit
hard for you to see--
it's also in the paper.
But on the right, you see
a top down photograph,
or SEM micrograph, of
the surface structure.
And it gives you a sense, a
little bit, of two things.
One is there's a lot of
surface morphology going on,
surface roughness.
But the other basic
thing that happens
is, as you're depositing
these materials,
they are lining up in sort of
a polycrystalline kind of way.
You do get some local
self-organization.
And you can see that also
over here on the left side.
If you kind of see,
there's little crystals,
or little threads.
And in here, you
can see a little bit
of the polycrystalline
structure.
And that's actually
one of the things that
gives that surface roughness.
It's not surface roughness
on the atom by atom level.
It's really these
preferential growth directions
in some of these grains, if
you will, as they're growing.
Only two or three
more parameters here.
Another one-- and this
is kind of neat, I think,
because it's a
nice parameter that
contrasts with the other ones.
The other ones are--
let's see.
Most of these-- things like
step coverage, film stress,
uniformity, resistance
uniformity-- those
are parameters of the final
wafer or the intermediate wafer
state that you want to achieve.
Deposition rate
and WF6 conversion
are both more
manufacturing parameters.
In some sense, they don't
really matter to the final wafer
product.
But they can matter a great
deal for the cost efficiency
or the time efficiency
of the process.
So WF6 conversion is what
percentage of the incoming gas
is actually resulting
in the deposited film.
So you might have only
1% of the tungsten going
onto the wafer and 99%
going out the exhaust pipe.
That's terrible waste.
It may have some
environmental implications,
but it also has a lot
of cost implications.
Because tungsten hexafluoride
is not a cheap gas--
very, very highly purified.
So I like this paper
in terms of they're
actually trying to track,
and keep track of, and model
the WF6 conversion rate,
and try to optimize
that parameter also.
Then finally, a couple
more parameters here.
Reflectance is basically
an optical reflectance,
percentage of light
reflected kind of measurement
of the surface topography.
So that's how they're trying
to estimate or correlate
to the roughness of
the surface film.
And then finally, another
manufacturing parameter
is reproducibility,
not just wafer
uniformity one wafer at a
time, but wafer to wafer
repeatability or
reproducibility of the process.
So they are actually making,
in this case, I think,
the assumption that pretty
much all of these processes
are more or less
similarly repeatable.
But they want to estimate how
repeatable the process is.
And we'll see that in their DOE.
They're going to basically
do some replicate
at one of the design points,
and use that to estimate
reproducibility.
So they're not
going in and trying
to estimate where the
noise or the variance
is minimum across
their operating space.
They're actually assuming
that that's similar, OK?
So here's what they
do in the paper.
Their goals are to build
response surface models--
just classic response
surface models.
And then, as I said,
the reproducibility
is really focused just on
the center point designs
and applying that
throughout the entire space.
And then, they want to use
these response surface models.
They want to qualitatively
understand some of the trends--
very good engineering
use, trying to understand
from an engineering point.
And then, they also want to use
these models in an optimization
kind of loop to try to
drive towards satisfaction
of multiple limits
or goals on those--
what was it-- seven or
eight output parameters.
Now, the paper does
refer to some prior work
on screening experiments.
In fact, these Precision
5000 tools and most FAB tools
probably have,
literally in some cases,
dozens of control settings, some
subset of which, maybe only 15,
are easily settable
electronically.
And another 15 might be more
mechanical, or other more
permanent adjustments.
But there's a huge space
of possible parameters.
The paper just refers to
prior screening experiments
to narrow down to
these four parameters.
So I don't want you to think
that they knew automatically,
up front, what four parameters
they wanted to play with.
There is a reference if you
want to go try to track it down
for their prior work.
It's actually in some
obscure conference thing,
so it's hard to find.
So the details exactly of what
they did in their screening
are not entirely clear.
But the point is, they
probably did something
like a fractional factorial--
a highly fractionalized
factorial kind of
design to explore
the space of just trying
to see what parameters are
significant, what influence--
what input parameters influence
the outputs that
they were of concern,
and then narrow that down to
just these four parameters
that they wanted to do a second
set of experiments-- which
is what's in this paper-- that
are focused on response surface
modeling, OK?
There's another
interesting, subtle point
that pops up in the
description of the paper.
Some of these parameters,
things like sheet resistance--
sheet resistance
is resistivity--
is it divided by per square--
the pure resistivity divided
by the thickness of the film,
so that the thickness
of the deposited film
will change the RS
measure on the wafer.
What that means is, to do a
fair comparison just of truly
the resistivity of the film, or
to estimate that, you actually
want to grow all of your films
to about the same thickness.
Well, if the deposition
rate is a parameter
that you don't necessarily
know, and you're trying
to model, how do you do that?
So in other words, if I run
for a fixed period of time--
maybe I run for 60 seconds on
each of these design points--
but I have deposition
rates that are
different by a
factor of 2, 5, 10,
I'm going to get widely
varying thicknesses.
And therefore, when I make
some of these simple sheet
resistance measurements, that's
going to be very, very tricky.
Furthermore, if my
thickness is varying
it makes a basis for
comparison of many
of these other
parameters really hard.
How about film stress?
Well, is it a film
stress that I'm
seeing because of the
thickness difference,
or is it truly intrinsic
film stress in the layer?
So what they've done is been--
and I think this is very cool--
they were very careful.
And they say that
they are doing this
to where all films are
grown to about 1 micron
thickness in this DOE.
What's sneaky is, I think
to actually do this--
which is also good,
because that is really
the thickness that's close
to their target application.
What's a little bit sneaky is to
do that, I think they basically
had to do prior runs, maybe
at each individual DOE point,
to do the run,
measure the thickness,
estimate the growth
rate, and then adjust
the time for the real DOE run
on each of the design points.
So I think that there's
a whole extra duplicate
set of experiments
that they're not
talking about that were done in
order to be able to normalize
and get a very nice set
of experiments in here
that they could
talk about and be
able to use to make the
right kinds of optimization
and judgment.
So it's kind of an
interesting lesson.
I think there may often be
additional experimentation
around your main
DOE that you have
to do in order for your main DOE
to really be a good, clean DOE.
Now, it's possible that maybe
their screening experiment
gave them some information
to be able to do
a rough estimate-- a good enough
estimate of deposition rate.
So it's possible they were
able to get that benefit
from their prior screening DOE.
OK, here's their
experimental design.
What they're going to do
is a central composite
with five levels at each design
point, which is pretty cool.
I think that's better
than the three levels.
What's one reason that you might
like five levels rather than
three, especially if you want to
build, say, quadratic response
surface models?
We haven't explicitly
done this before,
but for example,
on quiz two, you
were going from a linear
model to a quadratic model
and asking questions
about lack of fit.
In order to say whether a
linear model had lack of fit,
I needed a third design point
so that I could say, well,
does that third design
point give me indication
that the linear model
is not sufficient?
If I do three levels and
build a quadratic model,
and I want to ask the
question, is a quadratic model
sufficient, or is there a lack
of fit in the quadratic model,
can I do that with
just three data points?
No, right?
You can fit a quadratic
to three data points.
So you won't detect if there's
some other structure going on.
So in order to be able to
do a lack-of-fit analysis up
to seeing if a quadratic
model exhibits,
then you need at least
additional levels implicitly
somewhere in the design.
So that's kind of a neat
thing that they do here.
So what they've
done is normalized
all of their factors.
There are four factors here--
space, temperature, and so on.
Again, not just two--
in their case, not just two
of them, minus 1 plus 1.
But they use, with their
five levels, a minus 2
to plus 2 normalization.
But essentially.
They're doing up to five levels
on each of their parameters.
And so they're using
coded variables
that we'll see in the later
tables just like we're used to.
Now, of course,
the other benefit
of doing a screening
experiment is
that also helps give
you some information
about reasonable design space
for picking the range that you
want to explore
these parameters in.
Otherwise, they
probably would have had
to just go by prior experience.
But that's another advantage
of doing sort of this two-stage
experimentation with screening
followed by a more extensive--
either a new DOE, or adding
to the screening DOE.
So they're going to be building
second order polynomial
models, that is to say quadratic
models with both interactions
and then square terms--
just square terms in
individual parameters.
And they also mention
that they're not
going to do any transformations
of the output variables,
such as a log or an inverse.
OK, so we've already talked, I
think, about those two points.
So in the paper, they show the
variable test level is coded.
Here's, again, our four
inputs and the trials.
And if you look,
you can start to get
a very nice sense of what this
central composite looks like.
What they're
essentially doing here--
breaking it up into, let's call
it, three different segments
of design points.
What are these design points?
What do those correspond to?
There's a term.
We refer to those kind
of design points as?
Where does one of those
design points lie?
Take trial number one, right?
It's way out, minus
2 on the space axis
and holding the others at their
median or their nominal value,
right?
So that's out on the
end of one of the axes.
Then the plus 2 minus 2,
that's the other end of this.
So those are our axial points
in a central composite design.
They're sort of the classic
hold everything else constant,
vary one parameter at a time.
So they are giving
you unambiguous sense
of what that one
parameter is doing,
but not able to capture
interactions, and so on.
They're also exploring sort of
the outer limits of the design.
How about these points?
How many of them are there?
Looks like there are 16 of them.
Corner points, exactly.
So those are all
corner combinations
of four parameters--
4 squared, 16 different corners.
And then finally,
these are easy.
What are these?
Center points, right.
And so I don't know whether
they have seven replicates.
So the other points are
unreplicated, by the way.
So you might be a little
bit susceptible to outliers
in some of the other points.
But they have a fairly
reasonable number--
seven replicates at the center.
So that'll allow some
more or less reasonable
estimate of some of
the reproducibility--
some of the inherent
variances in the process.
They say, by the way, that those
replicates generally result
in about 1 1/2% to 5% 1 sigma
range in the output parameters.
The paper says they did
a randomized run order.
Why would you do that?
Why not just run--
you've got trial 1,
et cetera, et cetera.
Why not just run all the
way down to trial number 31
in this order?
AUDIENCE: To be independent.
To be independent
DUANE BONING: To be independent.
Independent of what?
AUDIENCE: Different
pressure, different pressure.
DUANE BONING: I
think you're right.
But as you changes
parameters, we're
only playing with
these four parameters.
But there might still be noise--
other noise in the process,
or drifts like we talked about.
And it turns out, in many of
these deposition processes,
you actually have to worry about
possible drifts, in that you
may get film buildup on the
inside of the reactor that,
over time, might change a little
bit the deposition process.
So by randomizing the run order,
you're randomizing the output,
and converting-- if
there is a trend,
you basically convert that
systematic trend into noise.
It may still
perturb your values,
but now, it does it
kind of distributed
in a random fashion
across all of your output.
And it will add to the noise--
change the
reproducibility values.
But at least then,
it's not fooling you
in a systematic way.
If there is that kind of other
drift, it will not confuse you
or alias with some
other parameter.
I have one minor
annoyance in the paper.
And so if you're writing papers
and you do a randomized run,
tell me what the run
order actually was.
If you're telling me
the data, I would love
to actually know the run order.
Because then, when I do
residual analysis and look
at the residuals as
a function of time,
I can actually go in and
see if there was perhaps
a systematic time drift.
And it really doesn't cost
much to do that in ink space
in the paper.
So for example,
here they had trial.
Some papers, you
will actually see,
they go in and might put
a number sort of right
beside it in parentheses
or something like that,
or another column in the table
or whatever, that tells me run
order, not just trial number.
So do that if you write
papers with data in it.
They also say they did
some outlier analysis.
They don't really
say what that was.
But they do note it in the data.
And by the way--
oh, I may not have put
this on the site yet.
I will also add the spreadsheet
with this basic data.
So if you want to grab this
later and play with the data,
and do some of your own
response surface model fits
with JUMP or some of the
other tools, you can do that.
Here's the output--
trial number,
and then each of the
seven different outputs--
so these are the seven
different outputs--
and basically just the
raw, measured data.
They also may have
asterisked or footnoted
a few of these, which
is a good practice.
They said, you know, weird
things like "indicates entries
determined to be outliers."
Or if they knew
something weird happened
with the measurement
of that particular data
point or that entire row,
they would note that.
That can be really critical when
you're interpreting the data.
And then, what they've done
down here at the bottom
is simply calculated things
like the standard deviation
across all of those.
I think that's across
just the replicate runs.
You can see that
underneath here.
Yeah, OK, so it
gives you a sense
of the percentage variance--
1 sigma percentage variance in
each of the output parameters.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: One of the
entries has an issue.
Doesn't that mean the
whole row has an issue?
So shouldn't that
whole row be discarded.
How can you, for example in
round six, have an issue in,
let's say, 8.1, and
say this looks weird?
And they're not going
to use it in the row.
DUANE BONING: Yeah, so the
question for folks in Singapore
is, how can you have just
an issue with one element
and not an issue
with the whole row?
Basically, I think it comes
down to some engineering
knowledge on what the
issue might actually be.
So in particular,
if you're worried
that there's something
wrong with the measurement,
then that does not necessarily
contaminate your measurements
of other columns.
If you think it's
really an indicator
that the whole run, or the whole
trial, was messed up somehow,
then I agree.
You would probably want
to omit that entire run
from your whole table,
or maybe repeat that run.
In this case, with
single-wafer processing,
it's probably an
easy thing to do.
AUDIENCE: I guess the second.
If we were experiments that
we heard that's an issue.
One of the numbers looks funky.
The fact-- and we want to
eliminate that whole row.
What does that mean
for our experiment
if there's, for example,
like, we only-- we
didn't replicate
the center point,
and now we don't
have a center point.
DUANE BONING: Yeah, so the
other question is if you do
have a bad data row,
how does that mess
up your data analysis?
And the answer is depending
on the kind of DOE
that you have, and the kinds
of analysis that you apply,
you can be more or less robust
to those kinds of missing data
points.
One of the nice things about
a central composite design,
and especially one where they've
got kind of these five levels,
is if you do that in conjunction
with response surface
modeling-- regression
modeling in particular,
the numerical
regression modeling--
you're fairly well off if you
have a few missing data points.
It would throw you
for a loop and some
of the shorthand formation of
contrasts that we talked about.
Because then, your
typical averaging
that's implicit in some
of those are wrong.
So you've got to be a little--
but if you do regression
modeling in conjunction
with a fairly rich--
sort of extra data points
are lurking in there,
extra degrees of freedom
that'd still allow you
to reliably fit models.
So the paper says the ANOVA is
performed but it is not shown.
I want to see the ANOVA table!
So, well, we can basically
generate those on our own.
And so in this case, if the
paper has the raw data in it,
I think it's OK that they
didn't show the ANOVA,
because I can regenerate that.
Papers I hate are they
don't show you the data
and they don't
show you the ANOVA,
and so you don't know
really what the noise was,
you don't know
significances of parameters,
which parameters--
often, they won't
tell you, really,
the significance level that
was used to accept a model, all
of those sorts of things.
So in this case, I'm
happy with the paper,
because I've got the raw data.
They claim that each of the
model is significant at 99.9%
significance level.
That's just their p value on
the F test for the whole model.
So these are very--
at least there is some
parameter that is significant
and influencing the output.
They report also r
squared, which is nice.
And for most of the
models, they are really
quite high-- in the
0.88 0.97 range.
The lowest one was
resistivity at about 0.79.
They also report
some lack of fit.
I mentioned a little bit
of evidence of lack of fit
for uniformity and reflectance.
This lack of fit for sheet
resistance uniformity
is really interesting.
And in fact, so interesting that
I think, a week from today--
if Dave is talking on Thursday--
I will spend a whole lecture on
modeling of uniformity response
surface modeling
approaches, spatial modeling
approaches appropriate
for uniformity.
The preview is, think of
the calculations that go
into a wafer level uniformity--
you know, the
calculation of that.
You might measure-- I
think they're measuring
49 points across the wafer.
They're forming sums
of squared deviations
and then taking a square root,
and then perhaps normalizing
by some mean.
Does that sound like a
set of linear operations?
No, there's a lot of implicit
non-linearity lurking
just in the calculation
of that metric.
And so it's not surprising that
there's quadratic lack of fit,
or inability of
a quadratic model
to deal with a
uniformity metric--
a spatial uniformity metric.
And we'll talk more
about that next week.
But, so they do
mention this at least.
They also mention some potential
lack of fit in reflectance.
I don't have an
explanation for that.
They conjecture it's due to
a very small pure error term,
so that you're able to detect,
with pretty fine resolution,
if there's any subtle
non-quadratic trends.
But they're not
concerned with it.
They still feel that they
have very good models.
It's also the case
that there may
be transformations
that could be applied
to improve these models.
And that also, for
this sheet resistivity,
or sheet resistance
measurement, there
might be natural
transformations that you
might think that apply.
In fact, if this is related
to things like resistance
divided by a thickness, and the
thickness grows linearly with--
maybe you have a linear
dependence on growth rate
or something like
that, there may
be inherent in there some one
over kinds of transformations
that might actually
be a better thing
to do, to take that
sheet resistance,
invert it, and model the
inverse of sheet resistance
as a function of the
input parameters.
So you could play
around with that.
And actually, that's a
fun thing to play around
with some of these models.
They didn't do
that, but you could.
And then they do show
the regression models.
Here's the output.
These are the regression
coefficients--
all of the linear terms,
and the cross terms,
and the square terms.
And what they've
done in this table
is report the fit for just
the significant terms.
If the coefficient
was determined
in their stepwise regression
to be insignificant,
they've left it off.
I don't think they
actually told us
what their criteria
for inclusion--
what their significance
level cut off was in here.
So that would be a good
thing to do as well.
But you can see, lots of models,
lots of second order terms.
These are interactions--
b1,1; b,2,2; b3,3; b--
those are our pure square terms.
And then these are interactions.
So there's a fair amount
of square activity going on
as well as interactions.
They also then use
those fit models
to start to form contour plots.
And this is how they start to
make some engineering judgment
about different trends.
So they would plot--
realize, they've got four
inputs and seven outputs.
You can't possibly have a--
whatever-- four-dimensional
dimensional input space
is very hard to visualize.
So what you resort
to are typically
sort of two-dimensional
plots where
you might plot one output
or two outputs as a contour.
So in this particular plot,
the solid line, I believe,
is growth rate.
And the dashed line
here is WF6 conversion.
And you can start to get a
feel for as, for example,
the WF6 pressure and the
temperature change what
trends you get in those two
parameters and what trade
offs you get in
those two parameters.
So things like as the
temperature increases--
so temperature
increasing this way--
the growth rate
kind of increases.
So the growth rate
is the solid line.
So pretty directly
with temperature,
that looks like a fairly
strong direct impact,
as you might expect with a
chemically dependent kind
of process.
So they can start to get a feel
for what some of these trends
are, and look at what, for
example, has the biggest
impact on growth rate
of these parameters,
and which have either
insignificant or small
in magnitude kinds of effects.
Now, they can also start
to do things like overlay
requirements or
conditions on these
to start to understand the
feasible operating space
for process design
and optimization.
So for example, if
your growth rate
had to be 500 nanometers
per minute or higher,
you might then have--
kind of shading on this
plot, you would say,
OK, I really need
to be above that 500
nanometer per minute contour.
And that tells me where I need
to be, at least with respect
to those two parameters in terms
of feasible operating space.
So already, it tells
you a lot just looking
at these plots of where you
might need to be in order
to achieve your multiple goals.
It may not give you a
numerical optimum point.
But all by itself, lots
of looking at the data
and plotting of the
data is really valuable.
And they do that for not
only growth rate in WF6,
but things like
resistivity, reflectance.
They start to look and
see is the overall design
going to be feasible,
what has the biggest
effect on morphology,
those sorts of things.
We found if you look
at their contour plots,
most of these contour
plots are reasonably--
these are nice,
semilinear kinds of plots.
Their uniformity plot,
these look bizarre--
very complex surfaces.
And again, that's a reflection
that this uniformity metric,
the spatial uniformity metric,
is a very complex function
of the input parameters.
What they then do, finally,
to round out the paper,
is talk a little bit
about optimization.
So what they will
have is, some of those
limits-- like I said, for
example, on the growth rate,
I guess it wasn't a
500 nanometer cut off.
They needed at
least 300 nanometer.
But they would
like to get that--
higher is better.
And they would basically have
different lower or upper bounds
on each of the other
parameters, as well as desires
to sort of hit either targets
or make those bigger or smaller.
Now, they don't really
describe very much
what their optimization
procedure is.
All they do is report
that using the model,
they were able to achieve
the following best
condition, which they report
and are very satisfied with--
so things like
very high, 99% step
coverage, improved or
fairly good conversion rate,
and so on.
So that's actually one of the
fun things one could play with,
I think, with the
actual data, is
apply some of the hill climbing
or other kinds of optimization
algorithms to this data.
They do note in the paper
that some of these constraints
or limits do not greatly
reduce their factor space.
They do not constrain
where they need to operate.
And that gives them lots
of latitude to be able to--
that's a good thing.
It gives them latitude to
play with those parameters
to achieve perhaps
some other goals.
OK, so what I want to do
in the last six minutes
is switch over here.
So are we ready to do a switch?
Because what I want to do is--
AUDIENCE: Why don't
you drop a pin there?
DUANE BONING: OK.
OK, what's that number?
So what I'm going
to be doing here
is basically showing you some
JUMP analysis of this data.
Oh, dear.
Maybe I'm not online.
So what I've
basically done is just
sucked in the raw data
and their input conditions
and their output conditions.
And we'll play with two things.
I just want to give you a little
bit of a glimpse here of--
AUDIENCE: We can't hear.
DUANE BONING: OK, excellent.
OK, can you see
that in Singapore?
Excellent.
All right, I'm psyched.
OK, so what I've done
here is use JUMP--
JUMP 7 in fact, which is a
more recent version than I'm
used to.
So some of the controls
are a little bit different.
By the way, I don't know if
you played with JUMP before.
As you're looking
at your projects,
there is a 30-day
free trial license
of the full version of JUMP.
So you can download
the trial version
if you want-- if you
want to grab it and play
with it, especially
for the project.
I believe there's also an
academic version that's,
like, $50 for a year
license or something, which
is pretty nice.
Because the commercial version
is hundreds of dollars.
So it's a nice package.
So all I did is I
sucked in the inputs.
These are our four
input conditions here,
and then our growth rate
and output conditions.
And I would always encourage
you, as a first step,
to explore your data.
Just look at it.
See if it makes sense.
Do univariate plot of outputs
as a function of inputs.
And by the way, there's
some very cool things
like scatterplot
3D, where you might
take three of these
parameters and plot them
against each other.
And so you get cool
things like this
that give you a picture of
the scatterplot as a function
of those three inputs.
Or I guess this is a
scatterplot of three
outputs versus each other.
See if there's some correlation
between these outputs.
You can do it one output as
a function of two others,
and so on.
So one of the nice things
I like about JUMP--
and you should look for it in
a good interactive package--
is that interaction.
You can actually interact with
the data, one of the things
that Excel is not good at.
So other tools like MATLAB
are good at this as well.
OK, so having done that, another
thing I like about JUMP is it
allows you to highlight
what are bad data points.
So I don't-- I can deal with
missing data points in JUMP.
So I've pulled those
from the paper as well.
And then I can
start to do things
like build regression models.
So there are graph--
whoops, I'm sorry--
analyze fit model.
So here, I might say, OK, I
want to build a model for--
I'll just pick one
for the moment--
growth rate as a function of
these four input parameters.
And I can do things
like, say, I really
am doing a response surface
model up to polynomial degree
2.
And it builds for
me the template,
if you will, for all
of the interaction
terms, the square terms,
all of those things
that if you were
doing this in Excel,
you would have to yourself
build those fictitious input
parameters.
But here, I'm
basically telling it
directly what the structure
of the model I want to fit is.
And one thing that
we haven't talked
a lot about that I
wanted to highlight
is how to go about
building the model.
I could go ahead and
do a full ANOVA--
a full regression in ANOVA--
and look at each of the terms
and decide what's
significant and what's not.
There is a stepwise version
of that same process
where, essentially, what we do
is, one parameter at a time,
add--
AUDIENCE: Hi, Prof, sorry.
Yes We just lost the connection.
We can't see a screen anymore.
DUANE BONING: I
wonder if I lost my--
can you see it just--
maybe we'll just transmit.
I'll try-- it's not
accepting the net meeting.
AUDIENCE: I can put
it through the Codex
so they can see it
one their screen.
DUANE BONING: Yeah,
it won't look as good.
But let's at least
do that since we only
have a couple more minutes.
AUDIENCE: I can't do anything
about your net component.
DUANE BONING: Yeah, that's fine.
So we're just going to project
so you can see kind of crudely
on the screen.
But the basic idea of
this stepwise regression
is that you can set
the significance
level for accepting
a model parameter.
And then, one step at a time--
so for example,
if I do this step,
it's pulling in additional
coefficients that
are of acceptable significance.
And in fact, I think the
probability, to enter,
it needs to be set to 0.25.
This is 75%
confidence level needs
to be achieved in order
to accept the model.
And I can keep stepping through.
And it iteratively is
basically making determinations
based on my setting
of significance values
to pull in or
discard model terms.
And if it discards a
model term, then it
takes those degrees of
freedom, throws them back
into the error term,
not purely as a function
of the replicate
error, but it does
this kind of stepwise
multiple regression
in order to build
the overall model.
So here you can
see, for example,
for this particular
output of growth rate,
you can see which terms
end up being significant.
You've got things like
temperature squared,
and temperature H2
pressure interactions.
OK, doing that, you can then
accept one of these models
and build another
column in JUMP that
is, in fact, the
prediction formula for one
of these parameters.
So for example, this might
be the prediction formula
for growth rate.
It now has that
polynomial model in it.
And one of the cool things about
JUMP, just so that it's there
and then you can
play with it, are
you can also now start to go
in and do things like profiler
or contour profiler for
optimization and exploration
of that design space.
So doing a simple
one-parameter profiler,
I might say, OK, I want to
profile growth rate and row.
I'll just do those
two parameters.
And what I've got is
this prediction profiler
that has the two outputs.
Growth rate is the
first row, and--
whatever it was.
Was it-- I can't remember
what the second one was.
It's a little hard
to see there--
formula row.
OK, so the resistance and
the growth rate as a function
of each of the
individual parameters.
So this is the
univariate dependence
depending on my current
operating point.
And then I can move
that operating point
and see how the other
parameters change.
So as I change temperature, how
does that affect my outputs?
OK, so it's kind of fun.
You can play around and see
how those things happen.
You can also do,
essentially, close
to what they did in the
paper, and do contour plot
explorations.
So I might, for example,
do those same parameters--
yeah, that's fine--
and actually,
now, plot the current operating
point, the response of growth
rate, row, resistance,
uniformity in the design space
so that I can see how
those things change
as I change my gap
spacing or my temperature.
And I can also apply
things like the limits.
Maybe I have a low limit
of 500 for the growth rate.
I need, again, 500 nanometers.
And what it does, it'll start
to shade out unallowable regions
to achieve those kinds of goals.
So this is just a
nice, interactive tool
that lets you do that kind
of dynamic exploration
of the optimal space.
So I'll put that data
up on the web as well.
And you can play around with it.
But this is kind of
where I'll leave it
for you to explore
more if you want to
with JUMP, either on this data,
or perhaps more efficiently,
on your team project data.
But wanted to get
this case study
so some of the capabilities.
So I think with that,
I'm going to break.
And we can chat a
little bit if people
have questions about team
projects and whatnot.